we have made our mark um i was talking
to my mom earlier this morning she knows
that you know this is the farewell show
and she was just telling telling me like
you guys really did
break the molds of daytime television
the real co-hosts are getting emotional
as they say goodbye after eight seasons
there was never a show
that looked like us right and i'm so
grateful and i hope that we are not the
last the hit talk show which features
co-hosts adrian houghton lonnie love
jeannie mai and garcelle beauvais will
air their final episode on june 3rd in
the preview lonnie reflects on the
impact they've made on daytime
programming
the whole purpose of the show
um
was that we would put on people that
normally would not get on daytime talk
you know and we were able to talk about
things that some people they just ignore
yeah yeah and so
you really have to when you look back at
eight seasons over 1300 episodes it's
phenomenal and it's historic
and lonnie's not the only proud one
jeannie told et last month why she
thinks the series broke serious ground
for others the show is the first of its
kind when you have a show that is by
minority voices for minority voices
yes i gotta say i didn't have a show
like that when i started and even today
i'm like you know where can i go that
has such a great culmination of
different aspects and women's
perspectives that come from different
lives and cultures
especially as an asian woman i don't see
that representation enough
the reel premiered in 2013 it was the
first daytime talker to feature five
women of color it launched with adrian
lonnie and jeannie plus tamara mori
housley and tamar braxton who both later
exited the show
in 2020 amanda seals joined the panel
but she left after a year and soon after
garcelle was added to the mix it's been
really cool getting to know them a lot
more lonnie is not a morning person
don't talk to her in the morning
but it's been really great and lonnie
makes it clear the women are celebrating
what they've accomplished over the years
this is actually a celebration and we
hope that our example with with what
we've done can continue don't let this
end get another show like this together
with fabulous women because we have a
whole future of things that we still
have to fight for yeah
and the co-hosts definitely have plenty
to celebrate
like in 2018 when they won emmy gold the
emmy winners how does that sound
i'm still in shock i could tell you guys
were in a little bit of shock
we couldn't even stop yeah
we nominated before we're like we
weren't yes i'm still in charge and you
just i don't know we're always the show
that feels like we're just working hard
to prove ourselves so tonight was a
minute where like god just took all
control and we were the ones just left
like wait we're we're not having to
participate we share this with our fans
our fans have been there ride or die
best man ever this is for them you know
the women also shared big life moments
with their viewers like when jeannie
announced her pregnancy last year
i am pregnant
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
she also had a gender reveal on the show
i am very excited to share that monaco
mai jenkins
is
a girl
[Applause]
and as genie's motherhood chapter begins
her work on the reel comes to a close
but she'll always have fond memories of
working with her co-hosts
are you keeping in touch with the ladies
absolutely yeah the girls we keep in
touch we have we have our text thread i
think that's the greatest and from here
on like the girls they're gonna soar i
mean g-money garcelle adrian lonnie like
you're not it's not the end of seeing
them
[Music]